quand on voit ce qu'a dit cette jeune
femme avec en parlant des pires que vous
récupérez pas ça aussi voilà alors
qu'une fois de plus encore de la
récupération comme moi je récupère les
chiffres du ministère de l'intérieur
ainsi les races il faut me le dire tout
de suite parce que ma mère tout l'effet
crucifix t il s'ils viennent d'articles
ils sont sourds c est mon expérience
propre expérience de beaucoup de
militantes de nemesis le disent aussi
donc au bout d'un moment il faut arrêter
de se voiler la face pour parfaire john
bost de mauvais goût et puis faudrait
peut-être vous répéterez de répéter
aussi mettre en avant un réel problème
donc on va passer à la dernière partie
d'émission c'est parti j'aimerais avoir
l'avis du ce de bon luxe montres de luxe
quand il entend ce que dit alice cordier
parce que ça doit te rendre fou ça ouais
ouais ça le dois me rendre fou mais j'ai
peur m 7 heures elle est agressée mama
ça va me fait pas peur mais c'est
pourquoi il vous fait peur elle me fait
peur comme en voit l'islam les trucs tu
vois c'est parce que c'est le buzz
maintenant si tu veux faire le buzz faut
parler que de voile d'islam et là tu vas
buzz et c'est ça qu'on l'aurait pas cool
santé comme ça ça oui parce que moi là
bas je vis en france et quand je vais en
vacances en angleterre je vois plein de
choses que ça n'existe pas en france les
deux policières mais dans le même pays 1
avec je ne sais pas couper la parole en
fait on est interdit c'est pas grave
mettez un voile ne serait plus belle non
c'est sûr mais tel sur celui de taper
votre âme je crois que vous parlez au
contraire par les violences conjugales
chez rim simple vous avez quitté les
dents donc violence quand je regarde
avec mollo avec mon nom est ce que
j'aimerais qu'on reste sur le débat
s'il vous plaît alice faut aller vite
faire le vide puisque c'est vite fait
vite fait vite fait mais qu'est-ce qui
se passe une petite déviation est ce
qu'il va même rang seriez anciens quand
vous allez chercher les trucs faut voir
vos sources en fait pour devrait cesser
des vraies sources ou pas mais les
jeunes ivoiriens vivent mal à la maison
elle vit bien vous inquiétez pas à la
maison la virevolte aussi quand ils
arrivent tout le monde libéré pas de
procès aura dû tous savaient même pas
c'est quoi l'histoire vous suivez
internet en fait naître comme ça vous
êtes à la recherche de la gratter chez
moi ils ont dit oui convaincant va en
angleterre en fait on voit des policiers
des gens qui travaillent avec les
turbans avec les trucs le voir il s'agit
en fait chaque heure en france que que
le
le voile est vue comme tu vois une sorte
de comme si c'étaient les hommes qui qui
menace et les femmes qui les obligeait
de mètres se voit alors que les femmes
c'est elle même qui est juste répondre
là dessus a prévenu que oui mais je ne
sais pas du tout c'est pas
spécifiquement un problème de l'islam
il faut bien comprendre ce qu'est la
france comment elle s'est façonnée en
fait la france c'est des pros vont
chausser des basques et bretons c'est
des gens qui n'ont aucun rapport les uns
avec les autres au départ il ya un état
central qui va faire une pâte un
amalgame chez nous et il ya je t ai pas
je n'ai pas interrompre une les bretons
et corses mais oui mais justement la
france aux français
il ya un principe d'égalité et d'unité
extrêmement fort dans notre histoire
hors jeu rebondit sur ce que tu viens de
dire qu'est ce que voulait dire
là-dessus enfin je vais parce que c'est
très intéressant là la différence avec
l'angleterre par exemple
effectivement en angleterre dans les
pays anglo saxons la raison sur
l'ambitieuse la raison est parfaitement
raison il peut y avoir des femmes
voilées policière bien sûr pourquoi
finalement le voile fait tant de buzz
autant de problèmes en france en bosnie
à la question et c'est l'usure fait sur
ce bonne et après vous répondrai donc
voilà monsieur refait sur ce buzz raison
très simple mais ça en fait à la base
une raison très simple c'est quand
jamais un onglet va épouser une
pakistanaise
les mariages mixtes sont très importants
chez nous en fait le voile signifie dans
la psychologie français sef on a comment
although exogames simplement vous avez
france elle se marie avec des joueurs
est différent la leur de leur origine
qu'ils voulaient ils prennent les femmes
ou un ou un mari hors de leurs deux hors
bassin origine il n'y a pas de haies
mais de préférence ethnique ou de
préférence religieuse c'est très
important dans l'histoire de piste pour
ici pour ça que le voile signifie la fin
des mauvais soirs se touche vous
toucherez pas à nos femmes
passat est venu avec un argument de fou
alors j'ai bien des arguments une foule
à prendre d'après toi tu es au max les
gens qui tapent sur leurs femmes truc
elle est au max allez au mac smartphones
elle est au max ça le fait le tour du
monde
hrl excisées trucks en pis taxe max and
roll en 4 4 y'a pas de trucs comme ça à
pour deux ans la femme les gens à peu
près un plan vient en débat à la cité
parce que c'était erronée ton truc mais
partie elle était partie chercher
fouiner
une tension